[Music]
Warriors
family the tragic loss of our beloved
Deon Movic has devastated all of
us coach Dei brought joy and Life to
every single day with his passion and
energy reg grieve for and with his wife
Natasha and his children Nola and Masha
his memory will live forever in our
hearts at this time please direct your
attention to the video board as we pay
tribute to Deon
movich you meet many people and you
share knowledge with many people and
then when you see things that you're
trying to do and when somebody is
improving and blossoming it's a great
feeling and it's a fun job I really I
really love my job so soon as we met we
kind of hit it off you know I could tell
he knew his stuff he was real detailed
he's very honest he wasn't afraid to
tell me when I was wrong and I kind of
built that confidence in him and start
building that trust and building a
relationship with him since day one Dey
was such a joy to be around I really
just appreciated his demeanor and his
love of life every day and that's what I
will forever remember him for is just
the joy he brought to this team to this
city he always just had a gleam in his
eye and a laugh and um he was just
constantly saw the good in people and
the joy in
[Music]
life deand is living a legacy of uh
smile on his face when I think about him
first thing that comes to my mind is
always smile on his face and just the
way he looked at uh people and life in
general watching that celebration of his
life in the crowd expressing their love
for Dey was um one of the most amazing
things I've ever
[Applause]
[Music]
watched
please direct your attention to the
court where players coaches and staff
from the Atlanta Hawks and the Golden
State Warriors stand together in unity
and in honor of Coach
Deni and now a few words from Warriors
head coach Steve
Kerr the world lost a beautiful soul
last week uh Dey was a wonderful friend
a hello basketball coach a great man and
most importantly a beautiful
grandson son husband and
father the mark that he's left on our
organization uh the last 3 years you
just saw all the pictures that was him
every day the smile The Joy the laughter
it was ever present and what he meant to
us
uh was a huge part of who we are he's a
part of our
soul the outpouring of love that we've
received this past week from all over
the world uh you could see the photos of
him visiting with all the opponents
players when they came in here we saw
the fans in
Serbia that outpouring of Love is a
direct reflection of the joy and the
love he brought to everybody he met so
tonight rather than
a moment of silence I'd like you to join
me in honoring deie his beautiful family
Natasha Sasha
Nia and rather than a moment of silence
I I'd like for all of us to give Dey an
ovation that he can hear up in heaven
thank
you
sir J
Movic forever our brother forever in our
hearts